when people have me on they expect me to
to make the case
for essential workers and of course i do
because everybody understands that case
and when dirty jobs went on nobody was
making that case so i felt special and i
felt like uh you know iconoclast out
there saying hey don't forget about this
one and this one this one
right now
while i still hold them in the absolute
highest esteem
i'm
amazed at how we've taken 35 million
people
and deemed them
unessential
that to me is something i reckon we're
going to look back on with great
linguistic
embarrassment
main question i think i wanted to ask
you that i think we'll sort of frame
everything else we're going to talk
about is that there seems to be a
narrative out there from a certain set
of people
um that that it's like oh going back to
work it's just too risky and no one
really wants to work anyway and you know
aoc had some version of this sort of
thing like only in america would we
value work so high and as a guy that i
have seen do the craziest jobs you know
where you're stepping in [ __ ] your hands
in this animal the bats
electricity water you can give me 10
other examples of the crazy things that
you've had people do
you work with people who would do this
for a living
can you just talk about just broadly
like the importance of work
relative to finding purpose in life
relative to just setting up the rest of
the things that you want out of life
because that actually is one of the
things that i'm most worried about right
now that as
we sort of
give away our day-to-day lives that
we're gonna forget that work is
important not i'm not talking about
slavery but i'm just talking about the
getting up with something to do because
it makes you some money so you can do
everything else with your life that you
want to do
so it's the frog in the boiling water
uh i share your fear it's not going to
happen like a light switch though um
what's the old poem not
not with a bang but a whimper
and the way it'll happen here is
people like aoc and others who genuinely
or maybe not so genuinely
believe
that work is fundamentally
another expression for drudgery
are going to make those points they're
going they're going to reduce it
to something that's purely transactional
that's that's the first step and if you
only look at what you do
as
a means
to make money
then
i i
then then then you're not an interesting
person
okay it's just yeah
it's such a one-dimensional way
to look at something that
should in my view and oftentimes does
define us you know it's our work it's a
it's it's the thing we choose to do
with the most
conscious chunk of our life
and so
to reduce it to a paycheck is dumb
obviously there's a giant transactional
element involved in it but there's so
much more
dirty jobs happened
because
because i couldn't follow in my
grandfather's footsteps which i very
much wanted to do my pop was a guy who
could build a house without
a a a blueprint he only went to the
seventh grade but he had the the chip
right in his brain that he could take
your watch apart and put it back
together blindfolded he could he could
build a house he could run pipe he he
was a master electrician steam fitter
pipe fitter mechanic architect all of
that well he was heroic
in his youth
in his time
for those things
today
he'd be uh
mr cellophane you know he's transparent
and
so many of those trades so many of those
those vocations have fallen
uh
into
into this gap between blue and white
collar they've they've lost their luster
and we're simply not properly gobsmacked
the way we used to be about the miracle
of modern plumbing or the miracle that
happens when you flick the switch and
the light comes on so so dirty jobs was
meant to be
a tribute to my grandfather
initially and it was
and then it became a rumination on
essential work which is interesting
right because obviously the headlines
have have have caught up with that
and that's really been my great good
fortune over the years i do average
shows
with low production value
but big themes
and i stick with those themes and every
couple of years the headlines will catch
up with them
dirty jobs and the people we featured
became weirdly relevant when the economy
crashed in 2009
and it's become weirdly relevant this
month
i've been on every talk show there is
to talk about essential work
and it's funny i'll tell you what
happens i mean look there's a there's a
poster i keep it on my wall to remind me
i put a pig on a pedestal many years ago
for a lot of reasons
and um
when people have me on they expect me to
to make the case
for essential workers
and of course i do because
everybody understands that case now when
dirty jobs went on nobody was making
that case so i felt special and i felt
like uh you know iconoclast out there
saying hey don't forget about this one
and this one this one right now
while i still hold them in the absolute
highest esteem
i'm
amazed at how we've taken 35 million
people
and deemed them
on essential
that to me is something i reckon we're
gonna look back on with great linguistic
embarrassment because that that that's
exactly what i wanted to ask you next so
continue continue no i'm
it's your but that i just realized that
was that was the question really like
when once we say to 35 million people
you're not essential it's not just about
the job that they do it's it's the
message that's getting across to their
lives which in some ways i actually
think in some ways if they can get
through it and then rethink what they do
maybe there is something else they want
to do but i don't think that's the
message that most people are going to
get i think we're going to leave people
with some sort of existential crisis
we're doing it it's part of the grieving
process i was saying earlier people are
coming to terms with the fact that their
vocations don't matter in the eyes of
virtually everyone
who has a show to host
because in our
in our well-intended enthusiasm to
celebrate the essential workers we've
done a thing we always do with the
language and i am i am not a politically
correct person i at least i try not to
be
but language does matter a lot
and you know in my own foundation when i
feel most comfortably in my own lane
i talk about education and the skilled
trades
and
higher education is a turn of phrase
that has become inculcated and when we
talk about the importance of higher
education well who would doubt it of
course we need big people with big
brains doing important work
but
what what does higher education imply if
not the existence of many forms of lower
education subordinate education
so the language bakes in a terrible kind
of analysis if you don't get a four-year
degree if you don't buy into the idea
that the most expensive path
is the best path for the most people
then you wind up doing something
they don't call it lower education
because that would just be crazy but
they call it alternative ah we have some
alternatives for you dave maybe you'd
like it over here in a trade school or
perhaps you'd be comfortable over here
in a community college or a fellowship
or an apprenticeship so we did that in
education and the unintended
consequences are breathtaking we're
doing it now
with the very heart of people's
identities and we're doing it around
this simple word we're not meaning to do
it but you watch
it's it's gonna come back over the net
with a lot of top spin people are
already pissed off about it i just don't
think they quite understand why
yeah let's actually back up for a second
and talk about your foundation a little
bit because everything you're saying
right now i think does get to a trend
that i've been seeing for a while which
is i've had so many guests who come from
academia and you know so much of our
national conversation is about outrage
culture and cancer culture and what's
happening at colleges and now because of
youtube average people and i mean that
in the best sense of average all of us
can can watch incredible thinkers give
lectures you can watch jordan peterson
lectures on youtube for free and maybe
get more information from that than you
can from a semester that you're paying
25 grand for so talk about your
foundation and and sort of can you just
relate that a little bit to what you see
happening with higher ed relative to
if you have a trade right now it's like
you are essential again in the best
sense of essential that's not i'm not
putting down the
non-essential maybe we can come up with
a better word for it right now
well we should because everything has a
season and part of the reason we're
locked in this endless feedback loop of
nonsense is because
we're in love with cookie cutter advice
and so we dispense it with certainty
and this is what politicians do to be
elected they have to they they have to
say the thing that's going to resonate
with the most people and so they wind up
they wind up retrenching to bromites and
platitudes and tropes that's what safety
first is you're a little bit of
everything that actually is a pretty
good explanation of you it actually it
actually is a pretty good explanation to
me i think i
cover those multiple dichotomies
fairly well yeah that would probably
explain why you've written roughly 37
000 books right how many books have you
written i mean i normally only put one
book on the table we put four here so
i've written so far i've written three
adult books yeah and three kids books
i've got another kids book coming out in
the spring and i've got another adult
book coming out
going head-to-head with jordan peterson
in january of 2020 oh
oh yeah
i probably will be on tour with him for
that book that means that we're going to
be in competition okay we'll bring it
uh-oh all right we'll see we'll see okay
so nice to uh to not actually have to
compete with with the altitude yeah well
do you feel like you're in competition
with anyone if that's an interesting
place to start off well that's i guess
there's a dichotomy there too because i
don't feel like i'm in competition with
anyone and i feel like i'm in
competition
that's just sort of you know in my
nature to just compete but
no i mean
in this
world that i'm in right now i don't
really feel like i'm competing with
anyone i feel like i'm just kind of
doing what i do
talking about what i like to talk about
writing about what i like to write about
and
hanging out with cool people most of the
time yeah pretty good pretty good all
right well i think 99 of my audience
knows who you are knows a lot about you
but for the people that don't and by the
way i should say right before we start i
was saying we have been trying to
coordinate this for about 27 years
right i mean a long time which is kind
of funny i mean it really says it's like
well we're two people that are that are
busy and it was hard to hard to really
make this happen but for the people that
know nothing about you tell me a little
bit about your history i was born and
raised in a small new england town
i was a rebellious kid
my
best way to rebel as a kid coming from a
small new england town was to join the
military so i joined the military after
high school i spent 20 years in the
military
and when i retired from the military i
started taking the things that i learned
from the military and teaching them to
civilian companies and civilian leaders
and eventually that turned into a book
and a podcast and all this other stuff
yeah so tell me a little bit more about
what you were like that made you want to
go into the military
what was that rebellious kid or whatever
that was yeah you know i just grew up
in a little new england town and there
was a lot of
hippies and just kind of kids like that
running around and
smoking pot and whatever and i really
wasn't into that and so
you know i think a lot of kids when they
rebel as kids because all kids rebel a
lot of kids rappel by drinking or they
do drugs or whatever they're going to do
and i went the other direction was like
into hardcore music and
eventually
said oh yeah i'm just going to join the
military because
that's what i'm going to do yeah
it's funny when you talk about it it
almost sounds like you're slightly
dismissing it but you had a pretty good
storied career as a navy seal
yeah no i i grew up in the seal teams i
went right in the navy right in the seal
teams and that's where i spent my my
whole adult life and it was a incredible
experience worked with a bunch of
awesome people and got to do things that
i had dreamed about doing since i was a
little kid what should we know about
like the life of a navy seal that you
don't get in the movies or or however
else we just sort of imagined these
lives to be
i would say the biggest thing to
remember is that that
people in the seal teams and people in
the military in general they're people
they're just normal people they go home
they got wives they got kids they're
trying to live a normal life and then
their job
requires them to do things that aren't
very normal and so they you know for me
i kind of learned to compartmentalize
what i was doing in the military
and when i'd come home and i was i tell
this to police officers and firefighters
and military guys today don't when you
get home
don't bring your uniform home don't wear
your uniform home like physically change
your take your uniform off leave it at
work put on your your civilian clothes
when you go home and be a civilian yeah
how hard is that though once you're sort
of in that locked mindset which
obviously has so much to do with the
things that you write about and why your
message actually is is working and
helping people
you say how hard is it oh it can be hard
it can be hard uh you know because
you've got
one life that you're living where
decisions are really consequential
and then
you've got your regular life that you're
living and things aren't that
they aren't as consequential you know i
i had a situation where i was at work
and there was a lot of stuff going on at
work they were
they were redeploying people to
afghanistan there was big decisions that
were being made at work
and i remember i came home from work one
day and like i said try to try to leave
my
work at work but i'm sitting there
thinking about how all this stuff is
going to unfold
and
my wife you know i got home and my wife
goes i can't believe this and i was like
what happened is is everything okay
and she says you know the
no it's not okay the the disney on ice
is the same night
some other events for the kids and i'm
just thinking
hey if that's if that's the biggest
worries my wife has then that's a
positive thing
then life's pretty good yeah life's
pretty good yeah so how quickly did you
realize that you wanted to sort of bring
these ideas about personal
responsibility and sort of owning your
life and all that
into
sort of that world the world where
disney on ice matters and the rest of it
yeah it's
it
i was about six months from retiring i
had a friend that was the ceo of a big
company and he said i want you to come
and talk to my executives about combat
leadership
and i said hey sure you know sounds
sounds cool so i went and did it and
when i got and i don't think he really
knew what to expect you know because i
look like a knuckle dragger and i'm at
least a good portion i actually am a
knuckle dragger and so he bring me in to
talk and
i i thought i think he was
maybe thinking i tell some cool war
stories and that'd be that'd be great
but i actually started talking about how
you lead and when i got done he came up
to me and said i want you to do this for
every division that i have in my company
and i said well you know i'm retiring
and he said well
i'll give you money
and i said
okay
so
i started working with all the different
divisionals and at one of those division
meetings the ceo of the parent company
was there and when i got done he came up
to me and said i want you to come and
talk to all my ceos for all these
companies that own and he owned like 45
or 50 companies so i went and did that
and when i went and talked to those
companies of course then a bunch of
those ceos came up to me and said hey i
want you to come and talk to my company
so that's kind of the the way that it
started and it didn't take me very long
at all i mean it actually was the very
first company that first guy that i
talked to when they started when that
group started telling me about the
problems they were having
i was sitting there thinking myself well
i saw these problems in seal platoons
when i was training steal platoons this
is the same thing it's leadership yeah
were you surprised that the big
successful businesses were having such a
leadership crisis i was surprised for
about five minutes and then i realized
that these are all human beings these
are the same human beings that are in a
seal platoon in an army company and in a
business and they're all they all have
the same
idiosyncrasies they have the same egos
the same personalities you can see it
all and when you've seen it all over and
over again
it becomes
pretty evident pretty clear when you're
looking at it and the last job that i
had in the seal teams i was training
i was running the seal training for the
west coast steel teams and this isn't
the training where you see like the guys
carrying the boats on their heads and
carrying logs around and doing a bunch
of push-ups and stuff the training that
i ran was the training where seals
actually learn to go into combat and
fight the enemy
and this is where we really start
focusing on combat leadership and so in
this training that i ran
we got to take seal platoons and put
them through really tough training
scenarios very realistic training
scenarios over and over and over again
so every night i'd basically be putting
a new seal platoon through another
training scenario which the next night
would be another seal platoon going
through the same training scenario and
then the next might be another seal
between going through the same training
scenario so
you take these different seal platoons
and what's different about a seal
platoon what's different about a seal
platoon is really just boils down to the
leadership because you've got 16 seals
on this the guys are basically the same
sure there's some there's a bell curve
there's some top end performers there's
some low end performers there's a bunch
of guys in the middle so the real
variation on their performance was based
almost 100 on their on their leadership
in fact it was 100 on their leadership
and so
i got to see this and i got to watch
these leadership scenarios unfold over
and over again and see what leadership
things worked and what didn't work and
and so by the time i i left that job and
entered the civilian sector i'd watch
some
random team of leaders inside of an
organization
and i'd say to myself oh they're
strategic messages and get down to the
front line troops they need to
communicate this better or oh their
departments aren't working together they
need to cover and move for each other or
their mission is way too complex and
that no one has any idea what they're
actually supposed to be doing so they
need to simplify this or the this senior
leader is making all the decisions and
therefore everything's moving really
slow and nothing's happening at a good
rate of speed so they need to use
decentralized command and it was just so
obvious when i started how much
of leadership in general do you think is
innate versus learned obviously you're
teaching people the learned part but
there has to be some element that's an
aid right yeah there absolutely is and
there's
the the
analogy that i give and i don't play
video games but i've seen it but on
video games there's you have a character
in a video game and you'll have a
certain level of intelligence there's a
certain level of strength and a certain
level of agility
and those levels are what you get and
then you work with them well it's the
same thing for a leader and there's
different
there's different characteristics that
you get that are good for leadership
right if you're someone that's really
articulate that's a great thing to have
to be a good leader because you want the
human beings that you're talking to to
understand what you're actually saying
so and different people are naturally
more articulate than other people
it's good to
be able to look at complex problems and
be able to simplify them right that's a
that's a very powerful tool to have a
really complex
thing to solve and be able to look at it
and say okay simplify it and then
simplify it not only for yourself so you
can decide what to do but simplify it
for your team so they understand what to
do that's that's a characteristic that
some people have
the the one that i bring up a lot
because it's very obvious is
is being loud
because
if you're in a leadership position you
need to be able to
make people hear you yeah and some
people are born with a very loud voice i
was luckily born with a very loud voice
and it's inherited from my genes right
and my kids inherited their my kids are
all can be very loud which is sometimes
problematic in the house
but if you can't bark a command so that
people can hear you in a machine gun
fight no one's gonna be able to do what
you ask them to do yeah so there's these
different characteristics and
you can improve upon them so if you're
not very articulate you can read and you
can write and you can speak and you can
become more articulate if you are not
very good at simplifying problems you
can start
looking at complex problems and thinking
about how you can simplify them and you
can get better at that
the being loud part is that there's a
definitely a genetic aspect to that so
sure you can learn to project your voice
more but some people aren't very loud
they're just born that way and so what
does a person do in that situation well
what a person does in that situation is
when they have to give an order they
tell one of the loudmouths in their
platoon to tell everyone to get over in
this other building
now and that loudmouth will pass the
word and so what you do as a leader is
you find members for your team that can
complement your weaknesses so there are
parts that you can improve and there are
parts that you can improve and
if you
the only real
impediment to improving is someone that
doesn't have the humility to say you
know what i think i could work on being
more articulate or you know what i think
i could work on solving problems and
making them more simple or you know what
i'm not that loud and instead of saying
you know what
that's not a good way to lead instead i
say you know what i'm not that loud but
billy over here is loud so i'm going to
let him put the word out when it needs
to get put out but if you have the
humility to do that you won't improve as
a leader have you found those people
that even if you lay out what the right
you know skills are that they have to
work on or where their blind spots are
et cetera et cetera that they just can't
whether it's ego or whatever else that
they just can't that you just certain
people you just can't get through to
absolutely it's it's a horrible
situation to be in and in the seal teams
those guys will get fired
in the civilian sector generally
those guys get fired
because
i mean you you go into a company and
you've got a ceo that is not listening
to anyone upward down the chain not
listening to the board not listening to
subordinates how is he going to improve
he's not going to and by the way why
does he need to improve he needs to
improve because his company isn't doing
well so but this person might think hey
you know i'm great i'm not going to
learn anything from anybody i'm just
going to keep doing it my way and that
guy's not going to stay in that job
because
they don't have the humility to say you
know what i'm probably doing some things
wrong that's why we're not making money
and so i need to change some of the
things that i'm doing so we can make
money
but if you don't have that attitude and
you're not humble yeah you'll end up
getting fired i said i'm prejudiced
against two types of people lazy people
and stupid people everyone else
i'm okay with you know yeah i want to
back up to say you said before about the
government because it was it was making
me think of wolf wall street so the
thing about the movie i mean the movie's
so freaking brilliant i won't make you
talk about it because you've talked
about it a bajillion times
but you know you base you're the hero of
the movie obviously and yet you're also
doing some illegal [ __ ] you're doing
some moral [ __ ] however you want to
describe it but you hate the feds more
you hate the people going after you more
and they're supposed to be the good guys
in this right because you're doing stuff
with the penny stocks or whatever it is
and that i think sort of captures what
you said about the government before
like they've done so much stuff now that
it's sort of like the sopranos you're
never rooting against tony he's killing
people and you're still rooting for him
does that tell you something about how
backwards everything is in an odd way i
think that the lines
of right and wrong morality have been
very much blurred i think people just
realize for example it's just my case
specifically like people know that like
what i did
was nothing compared to they did a
goldman sachs and merrill lynch and
these guys bankrupted iceland in greece
it almost took down the entire world
economy
and and no one went to jail like at
least i went to jail for a couple of
years and did my time and like i had to
pay the price i had to rebuild my life
like that was like a thousand times
worse doesn't mean that riding was right
but but people also saw like these like
this sort of you know i think people
like the almost the tortured soul type
like like i'm like you're watching me
walk off the edge why you stopped though
like you know so
you see there was goodness in me there
was misguidedness in me and and i think
people like that complexity and you
could root for someone who i think you
feel like genuinely they're almost their
own worst enemy they're not killing
people and even by the way with tony
what was tony you can root for tony too
but like in this case i'm not killing
people but you're saying why why and i
think people can see themselves
in a lot of the of the characters in
that type of movie and that's scorsese's
brilliance
like he doesn't moralize he just puts
characters up that are actually real and
complex and you're watching good people
do bad things in bed and and people that
are you know all terribly will do good
things when you look back on all that
like are you just like even when you
post pictures a lot of times on
instagram you'll post pictures of of
what you were doing back then you know
30 years ago like what you were actually
doing like are you like man that was
just freaking great even though how long
were you in jail for 22 months
so all right
a little more than jesse but yeah
another character in that right um
you know one thing i'll say is that
when i look back at what happened the
one thing i wish i did less of was the
drugs yeah the drugs did not enhance
things they
corrupted a lot of things and they made
a lot of memories like really
far less enjoyable and colorful than
they should have been for example i've
fallen asleep in the finest restaurants
in the world
i got booked for a speech in the next
month in monaco right and they've got a
beautiful suite at the hotel to berry
right and i was like oh yeah i fell
asleep at the louis 14th restaurant the
bowl of soup and then you know it's
twelve thousand dollar dinner i can't
remember it but i remember it's all
bread and i thought my wife had to pick
my head up out of the freaking soup
right so like that was like the story of
my life so that aspect i look back and
say i wish i could have you know done
things differently with the drugs um but
other than that you know when i look at
it you know i wouldn't change anything
because it was my it was like what got
me to this point in my life obviously i
made some mistakes i had a lot of fun
did a lot of things right as well uh but
i think looking back at your life and
trying to say i shouldn't have done that
i don't think it's healthy what do you
think kept you going like that you're
not broken now like you're so thriving
it's every time i'm around you and
everyone knows it like you're infectious
with your energy this is exactly who you
are off the camera like you just
freaking love life like what
did you ever get to a point where you
were like starting to break or anything
like that yeah of course i did i mean i
think that you know um the worst part
was before i went to jail it's like
you're dying in slow motion and that's
like where you know you can't because
you know you're going and you can't
restart your life and you know just like
you know it's like it was like i lived
in the big house still then taking this
like roam fly the falling empire of rome
like if you're watching the house
collapse or everything collapse around
me right
um
you know for me
the amount of pride that i took in
rebuilding my life ethically i can't
tell you like what that meant to me to
go out and prove to myself to my
children that was really not the world
to my children that that like that i
would just go out right again and just
do things so straight as an arrow and
empower people all over the world and
make even more money and like to me that
was like and that just like was like
something that just kept me going in the
early days and it just snowballed and
it's fed in itself and fed in itself and
um yeah my life today is far better than
it ever was back in the craziest times
of strand yeah that's got to be a crazy
retraining right to try to do things
fully on the up and up we were going to
try to do something and i have a feeling
we'll do something in the future but
even when we were in the little
negotiations and then things just moved
too fast you were basically like just
give me something and i'll make it work
like you didn't want to negotiate you
were just like let's make it nice and
easy and then things just happen right
so move along in a different way but
like
was that a real shift for you like how
you're gonna do business like actually
how you're gonna engage in that
so
yes and no i think one of the lessons i
learned was that
if you're a really good negotiator right
and you negotiate a deal where it's so
great for you and badly other people
that's not a good negotiation it just
ends up in a lawsuit ak steve madden
shoes like when steve came to me he was
very young he was naive and i took his
company from him legally and i took 85
because he didn't know better and all i
did was created animosity down the road
so i don't think a great negotiation is
when you
get such a good deal you [ __ ] everyone
else over and also just like i just just
refuse to cut corners like in my life my
value system right now is just simply
it's just the it's just based on
creating value of people so i there's a
reason why i haven't it is why are you
launching nfts yet there's a reason why
i haven't launched an empties because
i'm not sure if the market is ready and
i don't know i'll make a quick 10
million yeah but probably the people who
buy them might lose a quick 7 million so
i didn't do it i just didn't
i would love to have the extra money but
i have enough money i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna engage in transactions or any
business practices that i'm not giving
more value than i received and frankly
i've ended up making more money because
of that it's my greed shows me if i'm
greedy that means do that give people
more value because you make more in the
long run i did not get an essay book of
the things that you won't talk about but
i don't want to do politics because i
think it's a good escape this is this is
meta-politics in a way of course um
but in a time like we live in right now
where politics seems crazy everyone's
trying to destroy each other all of
those things
do you have any tricks that you use for
yourself or that you've recommended to
other people to scale back i mean one of
the things i try to show people is that
your world view just can't be political
yeah you you know if your worldview is
just politics you're always doing this
you've got blinders on and you need a
much bigger philosophical religious
whatever it is whatever your worldview
is it needs to be much wider do you have
any tricks because it seems like
everyone everywhere yeah and i know i'm
sort of self-selected into this thing
because when anyone sees me at the store
they want to talk politics with me but
but i do sense people it's making people
crazier crazy it's making people angrier
you know they just released this big
study about how depressed people are
right now and i
i remember when i started
being an entrepreneur
after leaving my brother's i pay 250 a
month for my brother's place to have a
room from his place right i started
making enough money to get an apartment
for
4.95 a month and it was the
scariest thing to write a check for 4.95
because i was like i don't know how i'm
gonna pay this next month but i got the
cheapest department i could in columbus
ohio
and i remember and i didn't have a car
at the time so i was walking everywhere
and i remember saying to myself i'm not
gonna get a tv
and the first few years i didn't have a
tv and i just focused on my mission and
my vision which was creation which was
getting customers and sales and adding
value to those customers and clients
and not having a tv was a big blessing i
love movies and i love tv so i would go
to the movies all the time but i
wouldn't allow myself to browse and see
chaos
on a screen
until midnight and then go to sleep with
nightmares from the chaos
so personally i tried to
i remember i had marianne williamson on
my show and i told her you know i really
don't watch the news and she goes
that's you need to watch the news like
you need to be informed especially as
like a white male you need to know
what's happening in the world
but you can get the news from different
places i don't need to watch
the tv to get the news i can check you
know apple news or whatever or get
someone to tweet me something and check
it out and people are gonna tell you the
news no matter what
right you can't you can't really escape
the news i try to focus on
i truly believe that when i focus on
giving to people and service
i'm a happier human being and and
research has backed science of happiness
that when you're in contribution to
someone else whether it's opening the
door buying a coffee having a
conversation listening to someone
when they're going through something
doing charity work whatever may be that
makes you the happiest when we're giving
to others so when we're focused on self
and what we don't have
suffering is the result of obsessive
self-centric thinking so when i'm
thinking of the news this is not working
in my favor i need to
this is an outrage or i'm not happy
about this because it's not helping me
you're going to be unhappy and i'm not
saying you shouldn't fight for what you
want and and and have things to change
sure but if you're going to be if you
want to be happier
focus on other people focus on service
and also don't watch the news and as
media companies ourselves we want people
to watch us but i think watch um
focus on
things that bring you joy i think as
adults we don't play enough
you know in my in my studio i got a
frisbee and all and we love to work hard
you know our team works hard but i'll
grab matt our ceo my friend and i say we
need five minutes just to throw the
frisbee like we need to play who plays
anymore i know especially if you can't
go outside you can't do this who is
playing well i'm chasing a one-year-old
dog exactly right so that yeah but i'm
like a big advocate of play over
watching tv
go do something fun
i went out to was it
i've been in l.a for eight years how
long have you been here uh about eight
years eight years
literally two days ago the first time i
went to
uh franklin canyon lake or park have you
been in this place i don't even know
what that is
this is
10 minutes from here it's a lake
in nature of like 100 acres in the
middle of la you can't see the city it's
literally in the middle of mulholland
never heard of this place it's
unbelievable i saw a photo of it
audience we got a lake we got a lake and
like ducks and turtles and everything
and i went there on sunday with my
girlfriend and our dog and it was just
like we're in nature we're hanging out
i'm not watching tv i'm not on social
media
i'm a big salsa dancer i love really for
15 years i've been salsa dancing around
the world
i play guitar i like to play sports work
out i'm just like go do something that's
going to contribute and benefit your
life and contribute and benefit someone
else's life when you do those things
you're going to be a better person
i'm learning spanish i'm trying all
these different things that get me away
from the train wreck of the news
so that's what i recommend don't obsess
yourself into what's not working for you
go be the change do you sense that right
now because of corona because of
protests because everything is is so
seemingly chaotic
that people are becoming more receptive
to the type of stuff you're talking
about because i can just for me
like i started gardening since we
started doing this i'll show you when we
get out here we've got a ton of we're
growing a ton of great stuff some
carrots man i got i don't know carrots i
got i got tomatoes i got cucumbers i got
zucchini i got broccoli uh peppers but
like i started doing that i'm cooking a
lot more david usually cooks a ton but
now i'm barbecuing all the time and like
i'm refining some skills and like i
think there's a unique opportunity in
this mess
to either come out of it more skilled
more refined more passionate about what
you do or or maybe realize that what you
were doing before isn't what you want to
do or all that stuff yeah versus some
people that i think are just gonna have
slogged through it and not really
thought about their life critically
enough and then they'll just be on the
other side and the world will be
different i'm on both sides here i
if you if you need to
take a pause and rest for these last
three months because you've been go go
go go non-stop for 10 years and you had
never taken a pause in your life this is
the most beautiful time for you to sit
around and do nothing and read a book
and lounge and not hustle so for some
people i think that is what you need
and
personally my philosophy is i feel like
this is what the world needed in general
is for us to take a pause with
technology being so fast with us on
social media most people on their phones
six seven eight hours a day and a lot of
his social media it's like what are we
consuming our time with
it's not what we're supposed to be doing
all day pretty sure it's not making us
happier it's not making us happier it's
making us more neurotic of like i need
more likes i need more followers i need
to uh what's happening in the news it's
just it's craziness and so for some i
think don't do anything and that's what
you need you need to re-evaluate why
your life isn't working why this
relation i'm seeing so many people i'm
not sure if you're seeing this a lot of
big personalities are posting we're
getting a divorce
we're going through a breakup you're
finally evaluating your relationship
you're trapped in a house with someone
every minute for three months you can't
start going do it do i like this guy you
can't escape anymore so i think people
are getting clear on what they want
because they haven't been clear for a
long time maybe partly but not fully so
for some people you need a pause you
need a break you need to evaluate you
need to take inventory of everything in
your life
and create a new game plan moving
forward you need to find some coaches
and mentors and have a game plan and go
take action for other people
i'm kind of in the middle i feel like
i've hustled more my business i've hired
more people i've been like more creative
than ever but i'm also going to the park
and relaxing with my girlfriend and my
dog on the weekends which i would never
do
and i'm taking that time to be in nature
so i feel like i'm trying to do both and
balance my personal life but then work
going kind of all in and getting clearer
like what does our audience need right
now what does our customers need what do
they need for the next five to ten years
if this doesn't change
so i'm a little in the middle and i have
empathy for both sides but i think if
you can rediscover what you want to do
in your life and who you want to become
whether you take action on it now or
just discover it now that's what we
should be doing this will be my fifth
august off the grid and one of the
things that i've noticed is
because i try to work on exercise and
diet and sleeping better and just
general digital detox and relaxation
i've noticed in the four previous years
that i've done this that my dreams are
more vivid during that time maybe it's
from being less distracted or something
so just broadly what the hell is going
on when we're dreaming and and what can
we do to i suppose
maybe gain more insight from our dreams
or or something to that effect
yeah and actually i have a quick
question for you so when you're doing
the detox will your sleep schedule
change where you may start to go to bed
a little bit later and wake up a little
bit later no it'll i'll be going to bed
earlier usually because i'm not doing as
much during the day so you know for a
portion of this and perhaps right now as
this is being aired i'm hoping that i'm
on the beach and it's a nice bright
sunny day and i'm under a umbrella and
it's about 3 p.m and i'm napping that
would be nice but then you know after a
day out on the beach by by nine o'clock
there's a good chance i i could be
sleeping and then and then i'm still
regardless of when i go to sleep at
night i'm an early riser that definitely
is something new to me at the last
couple years of my life where it's like
and maybe that's partly sunshine in l.a
you know it's sunny here usually at
about 6 or 6 30 a.m and i'm usually just
kind of ready to go at that point but i
probably will get a significant amount
more of sleep in the course of these 30
days or so
got it so firstly to stick a pin in the
daylight component um daylight will
absolutely regulate your sleep timing
and you can use it on both ends if you
get too much light exposure in the
evening
then it will block a hormone called
melatonin which is critical to signal to
your brain it's night time and it's time
to sleep
and so when we have too much electric
light or we're using our computers at
night it stamps the brakes on melatonin
and that's why some people can struggle
with their sleep at night so try to dim
down half of the lights in your home in
the last hour before sleep and then you
can reverse engineer the trick in the
morning get lots of daylight you know la
is a great place to do that and it
enlivens you because it now sort of that
daylight will apply once again the
breaks on melatonin and it will help you
wake up but coming back to dreams and
the function of dreams
dreams seem to rem sleep dreaming at
least seems to provide at least two
different benefits the first is
creativity
what we found is that it's during dream
sleep when the brain takes all of the
information that it's been learning and
it starts to fuse it together in
creative and innovative ways you know
it's almost like informational alchemy
and so we go to sleep with the pieces of
the jigsaw but we wake up with the
puzzle complete
and that's one of the creative benefits
of sleep you know there's a reason that
no one has ever told you to stay awake
on a problem
and there's a there's a very good
scientific basis for exactly that
the second interesting thing that we've
discovered and we've done quite a lot of
work in this area is that rem sleep
dreaming provides a form of emotional
first aid
and you can think of dreaming as
overnight therapy
and rem sleep dreams will take those
difficult experiences sometimes even
traumatic experiences that you've been
having and it acts like a nocturnal
soothing bomb and it just takes the
sharp edges off those painful difficult
experiences so that you come back the
next day and they don't feel as painful
anymore
and so i think in that sense
dreaming you can think of it as well
it's not time that heals all wounds it's
time during dream sleep that provides
emotional convalescence
and those are the two functions that
we've been strongly associating with rem
sleep dreaming what about people that
don't remember their dreams i always
find it so odd because i really do
remember my dreams every now and again
i'll have a notepad by the side of my
bed and i'll scribble something down
that i want to remember for the next
morning something like that and i do
find that there are insights and i can
piece together something that maybe i
couldn't have otherwise what about
people that just have no memory of their
dreams you hear about that every now and
again
yeah it's not infrequent it's not
necessarily pathological it's not
something that you have to worry about
or go and see your doctor
about we don't truly understand why
there
are those individual differences we
certainly know that they are present but
we also know that those people who say
look i just don't dream
it's not really that you don't dream as
you said it's that you don't remember
your dreams because if i bring those
people into my sleep center here at uh
at university california berkeley and we
can clearly see that they're going into
dream sleep and in fact if i go into the
bedroom well when they're in a rem sleep
phase and i wake them up and i say can
you just tell me what was going through
your mind before
i woke you up they will say it's the
strangest thing i was having a dream for
the first time
it's just that when they wake up in the
morning that memory seems to evaporate
too quickly and it doesn't seem to be
committed to conscious memory
recollection
does it mean that that memory isn't
there at all i actually don't think that
that's true i think it's quite possible
that we remember much more of our
dreaming lives than we are consciously
aware of or that we have conscious
accessibility to but what we know from
brain science is that implicit memory
mem information that you're not
consciously aware of can still
profoundly change your decisions and
your actions and your behaviors so it
leads to a wacky hypothesis that in fact
you know much more of our waking life is
determined by our imprinted dream life
but we just don't have conscious access
to that dreaming and i say that because
you know i'm sure you've had that
experience too where you wake up and you
think
i was dreaming i know
what was that dream what was that yeah
it's just gone and then two days later
you know you're getting into your car
and you see the keychain and it
instantly triggers the unlocking of the
memory of that dream
in other words that memory was always
there
it just you'd lost the ip address to go
and find it for conscious recollection
and if it's still there it could still
be changing your behavior
all right i said the dreams was the last
question but i'll give myself one bonus
question here which is do you have one
other tip or trick that i can
incorporate into this month so that i
come back as well rested and ready to go
and be back in the
crazy political and cultural fight that
i find myself in 11 months out of the
year
you are a brave brave man knowing what
you do and i admire it greatly i am far
too thin-skinned uh to be doing what you
do but you're definitely a wiser man so
let's not rush to judgment i probably in
the past 45 minutes just proven that to
be wrong as well but i will give you one
conventional tip and one unconventional
tip great the first conventional tip is
regularity if i could give you one
single thing to start doing go to bed at
the same time wake up at the same time
no matter whether it's the weekday or
the weekend and regularity is king
and the reason and because i don't think
people respond to rules that are just
barked at them they respond to the
reasons not the rules and the reason is
this that your brain has its own 24-hour
clock
and it responds best to
wrecking sort of the recognition of
regularity so when it's getting
regularity it's going to anchor your
sleep and as i said improve the quantity
and the quality of that sleep so aim for
regularity no matter what day it is
in terms of an unconventional tip and
this may sound a little bit strange but
if you have a bad night of sleep and
everyone has them you know i am not
immune just because i know a little bit
about sleep i have got my big share of
bad nights and i've had my own bouts of
insomnia that i've battled and struggled
with
but after a bad night of sleep
people will say what should i do and my
answer is do
nothing
and what i mean by that is don't wake up
any later
don't drink any more coffee the next day
don't nap during that day and don't go
to bed any earlier than you would
otherwise
do nothing just stay the course and
repeat the same behavior because if you
wake up later
then you're not going to build up enough
of that sleep pressure that we spoke
about for you to fall asleep at your
normal time because you slept in later
and second if you go to bed too early
because you think last night was so bad
i should get to bed early
your body is not expecting to sleep at
that different time that new earlier
time so you're just going to lie in bed
awake tossing and turning and it's going
to be even worse
and then obviously caffeine and naps
we've spoken about too so the best
unconventional advice if you've had a
bad night of sleep is do nothing stick
to your routine if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're both right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell